what's up guys it's Claire here back
again with another iPad review video
today we are taking a look at Apple's
newest addition to the iPad family the
new 2022 iPad Pro Model now the new iPad
features a large 12.9 inch liquid Retina
xdr Display powered by the new M2 Chip
I'm pretty excited to see all the work
that comes out of the users of this new
iPad because of all the possibilities
that Apple presents to us the higher GPU
means more capacity to run large
softwares like after effects or
illustrator for long periods of work so
students creatives or even passionate
Hobbies can enjoy their flow with little
to No Interruption with the larger iPad
also comes the larger magic folio with
wireless keys and trackpad for working
on the go I can see this being popular
with students and working adults alike
when they crunch some work on the train
on the bus one of the most stunning
parts of the New Gen iPads is definitely
the liquid Retina xdr Display it shows
true tone the darkest blacks and
showcases a stunning 4K video watching
XP appearance like no other this is a
feature of the iPad that benefits
creatives the most especially people who
are working day in day out with precise
color schemes and lighting even for
myself I love how colors are so accurate
that my work looks great from iPad to
print another win for creatives
another feature I enjoy is the split
view function on this bigger display
with a bigger display you will be able
to get more real estate for each tab you
have open this makes it easier for those
writing research papers or referencing
photographs when drawing and that's not
all with the iPad OS 16.2 Apple has
expanded on three noteworthy apps which
would make a great companion for
collaborative work and productivity
freeform is a new productivity app with
a flexible canvas allowing users the
ability to see share and collaborate all
in one place without worrying about page
sizes and layouts and with full support
for the apple pencil freeform will allow
collaborators to add virtually any kind
of file audio video images PDFs
documents and web links to the canvas
and preview it online without leaving
the board now for those who would like
to have a more desktop-like experience
and capitalize on the power of the M2
Chip stage manager can now support
external displays allowing up to 8 apps
to be used at once I find this very
useful at home as the added review real
estate really helps with my organization
and workflow last but not least what I
consider a very well thought out update
for the second generation apple pencil
and the M2 iPad Pro is the apple pencil
hover feature the apple pencil hover
shows you exactly where your pencil will
touch down on your display so you can
write sketch and illustrate with greater
Precision so you can preview any marks
before you make it and the apple pencil
hover just makes everything you do with
the apple pencil even more effortless
one bonus feature I like about the iPad
OS 16.2 is this quick and neat little
way of creating stickers from just about
every kind of image you could possibly
find it's called photocard it's a new
photo collage function that allows users
to select the subject from their photos
and drop it into notes or iMessage and
it's my new favorite thing the cutouts
look great and it's fun to create
stickers easily without having to go
through so many steps like downloading a
sticker app and it makes note taking a
lot more fun that's three well four
things I'm excited about the iPad OS
16.2 do note that we are running a beta
version of this firmware update I'm sure
that the iPad Pro will be even more bang
for bug once the iPad over 16.2 launches
officially granted even though the iPad
Pro is great for its performance right
now I still rely on a solid laptop for
more GPU intensive projects for Maya
After Effects and illustrator and you
know what's a great laptop for
productivity let's take a quick moment
to talk about today's sponsor MSI this
video is brought to you by MSI meet the
summit e16 flip featuring the latest
12th gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
now back to the iPad Pro it is still
undoubtedly the quickest way to get
started on drawing on the go the drawing
experience on the iPad Pro feels very
akin to drawing on an A4 Sketchbook so
the transition from traditional to
digital medium is not that jarring at
all I appreciate that a lot and Apple
has made that switch from paper to
screen very seamless I use procreate for
drawing and sketching for the most part
which brings me to a question that is
often asked procreate canvas sizes for
those looking to get the 6th generation
iPad Pro for procreate procreate limits
the number of layers you can place on
artwork based on its size and also the
power of the iPad so let's see what the
iPad Pro 2022 can offer our
multi-layered artists for canvas size A4
211 layers for canvas size A3 103 layers
for canvan size 4x6 photograph
865 layers and for typical screen size
of 1920x1080 pixels 902 layers
and there you have it I would say that
the iPad Pro has gotten a few upgrades
since last year between my current iPad
Air and the new iPad Pro I think I would
choose the iPad Pro 2022 for its larger
size and higher processing power
of course there are more features the
iPad Pro offers even just for leisure
and entertainment and I'm sure those who
are planning to get the 6th generation
iPad Pro will benefit a lot from it
however there are cheaper models of the
5th generation iPad Air and the 10th
generation iPad so Apple's got you
covered based on your budget I hope you
found this video useful and if you have
any questions for me please leave them
in the comments below remember to like
subscribe and check out my other videos
from Geek culture
eyeballs